WE DON'T KNOW WHAT IT MEANS.
WHEN WE FOUND OUT WE WILL TELL
YOU IMMEDIATELY.
IN 2015, TWO ISLAMIC
EXTREMISTS ATTACKED A MUHAMMAD
CARTOON CONTEST IN
GOVERNORLAND, TEXAS.
THEY WERE BOTH KILLED BY THE
POLICE BEFORE THEY KILLED
ANYONE ELSE BUT IT COULD HAVE
BEEN A MASSACRE AND IT WOULD
HAVE BEEN THANKS TO THE F.B.I.
UNDERCOVER AGENT EGGED ON THE
ATTACKERS AND TRAVELED WITH
THEM TO ATTACK SITE AND FLED
WHEN THE ATTACK BEGAN.
NO EFFORT WAS MADE TO STOP
TERRORISTS BY THE F.B.I. AND
NO WARNING GIVEN TO THE LOCAL
POLICE.
BRUCE JOINER ON THE SECURITY
GUARD ON THE SCENE AND WAS
SHOT IN THE ATTACK.
NOT SURPRISINGLY HE IS SUING
THE F.B.I.
HE JOINS US TONIGHT WITH HIS
ATTORNEY SAMUELS.
THANK YOU FOR BOTH FOR JOINING
US.
BRUCE, FIRST TO YOU.
THIS STORY IS SO INCREDIBLE.
SO HARD TO BELIEVE THAT THE
F.B.I. WOULD PARTICIPATE IN
THAT AN F.B.I. AGENT
ACCOMPANIED THE GUYS TO THE
SCENE OF THE SHOOTING?
>> HE WAS BEHIND THEIR
VEHICLE.
HE WAS TAKING A PICTURE AT THE
SPOT OF THE SHOOTING, SECONDS
BEFORE THE SHOOTING BROKE OUT.
>> Tucker: SO WHAT COULD
POSSIBLY -- AGAIN THE STORY
HAS BEEN AROUND FOR SEVERAL
YEARS BUT THIS HASN'T
PENETRATED TO THE EXTENT IT
SHOULD IN THE PUBLIC CONSCIOUS
NESS.
WHAT WOULD BE THE REASON
KNOWING A TERRORIST ATTACK WAS
GOING TO TAKE PLACE AND
ALLOWING IT TO HAPPEN ANYWAY?
>> WHAT IS INTERESTING ABOUT
IS IT THE F.B.I. IN THEIR
COURT FILINGS SAID THIS WASN'T
A ROGUE AGENT.
THIS WASN'T SOMEONE THAT WENT
OFF OF THE POLICIES.
HE ACTED EXACTLY ACCORDING TO
THEIR DIRECTIONS FROM THE TOP
DOWN.